foreign
your way right into a flashback I guess
the present and the future can go [__]
themselves why are you laughing being
confused why the people on drugs are
laughing and you're not talking about
porn the golden shower girls the
disrespect of mistaking television
Brilliance for pornography I swear on
the names of B Arthur McClanahan is
still Getty and Betty White I will
strike down upon you with great
Vengeance you are
Dorothy of course I'm Betty White you
were Rose [__]
and for the record Betty White wouldn't
do a common ass crime like bank robbery
she'd do some Queen like hacking all the
credit reporting agencies and erasing
everyone's debt or removing ahead from
Mount Rushmore will it get through my
skin if it can't nothing can yeah
nothing except the tool to put the
tracker in there in the first place
bladder was fine damn it I don't need to
see you digging into a bleeding wound
how am I supposed to finish my Funyuns
show finally gives us a scene of these
Heroes actually stopping crime and I'm
sure that's all that will happen here
nothing will subvert that nothing at all
we are heroes that's what Heroes do
stealing your line from the god of
hammers I mean Sparkles I mean Thunder
no no it's definitely Sparkles this suit
is so rigid I can only imagine that
homelander has the most uncomfortable
boner right now
Mutual murderbation Dave rats are like
uh Pokemon forgetting that there are
literally Rat Pokemon like Raticate and
now I'm reminded that Ash traded is
butter free for one like a [__]
dumbass so here's a sin for reminding me
of that episode tired killing people for
money despite all the evidence to the
contrary Frenchie still thinks he has
the moral High Ground in this argument
well well don't kill you makes you
stronger bringing Frederick Nietzsche
into a conversation where you've been
reminded of shooting a woman we better
have us a little Deco at this loony bin
I let butcher's dialogue tries very hard
to prove he is British while
contributing to the stigma of mental
health issues this is just the demo of
course we're going out to Lil Nas X for
the official version going through all
the trouble of hiring little Nas X and
not letting him write the song should
you guys even listen to Call Me by your
name I had to sell princess guitar now
he's just the soup formerly known as the
owner of Prince's guitar talk about
getting an ass with a soup can wait
would you are we talking about an open
can or does it have to be soup why not
just a can of vegetables wouldn't that
just you know what once in for giving me
more questions than answers Mr Eiffel
Dolphins would you like a Fresca I
thought Fresca had been discontinued but
alas I was wrong to the sin is that
apparently a lot of people answer this
question with yes Sage Grove a proud
subsidiary of global Wellness Services
which is a subsidiary of a guess we all
guessed it too so so I don't know why we
needed this Exposition or ymm waited
till everyone was getting out of the van
to deliver it weaponized Xanax the
grenades you used on Behemoth during the
bank heist got a soup activated by rage
so you simply take away his rage turn
him into a cupcake that sounds like a
very specific weapon how did he know
he'd be going up against the specific
soup whose weakness is being chilled out
also the show suggests that all it would
take to subdue the Hulk is Xanax so the
sin is Marvel and cold snap two months
ago male chemical a month before that
okay cold snap is a badass superhero
name but Mount chemical where did you
get that one Walter White's Justice
League fan fiction pairing your 25 red
roses with [__] baby's breath what
amateur did you get these from
homelander a real florist would have
used snapdragons or pin cushions the
woman gave you a hand job in the alley
and this is how you repay her step up
your game you milk addicted Maniac yeah
I see him and thanks to this bright
flash of light so did every other person
on this side of the facility seriously
you brought the one soup whose power
makes her impossible to hide
what happened to you're looking well
yeah no thanks to the 50 caliber round
that she pumped into my chest we have no
reason to believe these bullets are
bigger or better is his plan just to
piss her off Stormfront manages to fly
past them and see nothing despite them
standing outside their van under no
cover whatsoever needs help hurry up
please this works because the security
guard thinks that he'd be the person
that the hospital staff would turn to
during a serious medical emergency
they never talk about this murder ever
again whether he's constantly vomiting
this acid or just doing it on cue with
the camera movements we do not need to
see anyone puke have our God damn
brother's Gotta Love sausage foreskin
shadowing that orderly
you look familiar to you I'm saying Jena
say paw instead of just no this
successful test subject gets ruthlessly
roasted for asking to talk to his sister
and not because such things make someone
all that hard to deal with but because
the boys needed a shocking way to find
out that this orderly is the infamous
Lamplighter
okay but why are you drawing your gun
now are you gonna shoot the surveillance
footage can fire blow a hole in a door
like this perhaps did the story need a
way for this super dangerous soup to be
accidentally freed absolutely do you
remember that extra helping craft shells
and cheese that I snapped you oh
they swapped crafting for Velveeta in
this universe you monsters does this
card not know what they do here or the
odds of the soup could be bulletproof
then why would VOD equip these cards
with regular guns why would the guards
themselves not all be soups this was an
accident waiting to happen
metal doors from their hinges what
exactly was keeping Cindy secure in her
own cell she didn't need Lamplighter to
melt it right could Cindy have escaped
anytime she wanted this is a dumb
superpower to have if your outside
skiing isn't also immune to being burned
by your own acid now that I've gotten
that off my chest how did his lips burn
off there should be a burnt head with
two perfectly good lips all puckered up
wow that was cool and we get to see this
guy uses power oh [__] I need power we
got pretty
butcher would be [__] diabolical at
TV sins oh wait did we already use that
one hang on I gotta look through some
past boys episodes uh-huh oh yeah uh
yeah we we did use it well since we use
the same sin twice you're not qualified
for our sin rebate program simply send
us a printed selfie of you holding up
pictures of the two identical sins via
self-addressed stamped envelope and you
will see a sin removal within six day
business years why would you need to
explain
choking your girlfriend without explicit
consent and establishing a safety word
for men in seven-figure debt a heart
condition and a heavy withdrawal do you
really think you have the luxury to get
up and leave people who use the word
luxury like this just people who use the
word luxury in general let deep tell you
his truths no one makes a joke here
about the Deep getting deep you were
telling me the night that I torched
those kids straight up admitting to
torching Children what the [__] do you
think you are Anakin Skywalker don't do
it don't you dare do it Frenchie now
he's gonna do it yep he's flashbacks
positioning FBI need to come and do your
vehicle a bit of an emergency even
though it would be much less confusing
for Americans butcher never pretends to
be MI6 or Interpol FBI it's a really
you're even American hold up there guy
who's only here to be killed off his way
to create a moral dilemma for Annie for
all you know butcher could be a
naturalized U.S citizen which would make
him eligible to apply for the job if I
wanted to boost some Wheels it wouldn't
be a [__] Hyundai my grandfather
commenting on Kia boys Tick Tock somehow
makes its way into the episode if you
stay back this will stand off for all of
the sometime and he's able to control
her powers well enough to cauterize a
wound but not well enough to not
accidentally kill that guy who she will
find out was a father so she can feel
even more guilty and sad about it so
Mary did purple fool some other rods and
ends I'll make a knockout Mom I love
exploring Frenchy's Ingenuity but why
haven't they tried a window even if they
have bars we've already seen Lamplighter
melt his way through that prison door I
figured you boast about it to homelander
I'm not a [__] animal well you do
burn people alive for a living
Lamplighter I wouldn't call you a saint
either I told you I have something
important
than us yes since it's about keeping
them out of prison Why do shows pretend
words are so hard to just say oh thanks
your approval means everything to
do sarcasm might have made sense if an
hour ago you weren't so desperate to
know why he disapproved of you you know
that I hate thought as much as you do
you know that but it doesn't even matter
to you you can't have it both ways
Starlight he said thanks you said no
prob move on that's it these people are
test subjects they're trying to
stabilize the V Xbox now that they've
had their breakfast club moment they're
all friends and Lamplighter can finally
tell the audience all about what's going
on in this facility why would I do that
it's gonna [__] up the movies the
merchandise they don't tell me they just
make me burn the evidence okay but who
is they vot doesn't tell you why or the
script writers for this episode didn't
tell you why because it kind of seems
like the latter I'm pretty sure this is
what happens when you spend too much
time working your love gherkin after all
those reps it gets strong enough to
strangle you with the same want and
disregard for decency that you've shown
it all these many years and if none of
that turns out to be true then once
again the sin is the many failings of my
high school health class also could the
struggle against this powerful and
seemingly prehensile man-made of a
metaphor be about fighting the
patriarchy debate I just killed six
subjects out there like a [__] teddy
bear picnic well I guess teddy bear
picnics are nowhere near as cute and
cuddly as I would have thought just
needs a couple of days for this Vaseline
to kick in what are you a [__]
pharmacist just say antibiotics like a
normal person also we don't get to see
butcher explain the shrapnel sticking
out of his friend in a way that results
in no one at the hospital calling the
cops I'm gonna Postmates sugar fish it's
2023 and this is a sentence that makes
sense Maeve left the phone hooked up to
the GoPro because no one questions a
GoPro on its own but when it's hooked up
to another device you better believe
it's got some incriminating evidence on
it cigars she unplugs the Gable and then
it's magically plugged back in boom
quick efficient continuity scene
this camera is surprisingly good at
picking up very specific plot important
Dialogue on a Plane full of terrified
screaming people
oh yeah watch me but also just remember
what they always say sometimes the sin
lord taketh away and sometimes the sin
lord giveth it's my job job it's my job
I cannot punish him as much as he
punishes himself if that mentality Works
let's never prosecute anyone for any
crimes and just let self-punishment
guide Humanity to its bright utopian
future we'll never have to lock up
murderers arsonists or people who talk
to you while using the urinal ever again
he was a lovely dancer oh yeah nobody
had moves like Himmler he was especially
good at the worm after he took that
cyanide capsule
oh yeah
I just burned my tongue remember me
and my soulmate me [__] oh boy looks
like we got ourselves a good old
fashioned car chase and his ax body
spray oh I mean that's how Vin Diesel
must smell he smells like tuna fish oh
boy looks like we got ourselves a good
old bilingual blood Fest he gave me the
first successful V injection don't be
gross Tammy oh boy looks like we got
ourselves a good old Dana's tart
oh hell no